- Is this for the Oklahoma job?
- It’s the Week 14 playoff picture.
- Oh...yay.
- Hey, I'm late-season Lenny! The main star of the Bucs!
- ELISHA, YOU SCARED BRADY AWAY AGAIN.
- WELL, YOUR FOREHEAD IS—
We’re trying to make a perfect picture.
- OK, but no one's good enough.
- Aw.
- Oww.
- Ummm, I blame Detroit!
- Still?
- McCarthy, what's your deal?
- We’re all vaccinated in some way.
- THERE AIN'T NO SHADOW COACH. LOOK AWAY.
♪♪♪
- Let's get the good AFC teams in.
- I'm too strong for my crutches.
- We realized we needed to ManningCast the parts.
- I could be a contender.
- I don't believe you.
- I'm the three seed!
- ♪♪♪ I COULD BE A CONTENDER! ♪♪♪
- I could be a contender?
- Hey, kid…I could be a contender.
- We’ll see if the makeup folks can get rid of the whole, you know, Bengals thing.
[Peyton Manning:] Where’s Deebo? He's supposed to play two roles.
- Time for the playoff picture...Taylor's version.
- Sorry, I was in the wrong studio.
- We're like a Lifetime movie.
Quality doesn't matter here. The fans eat up whatever we give them.
- [Together:] Got it.
- Push.
- Push, you push.
- You don't pull.
- Pull? Sorry, nothing is easy for us!
- Omaha, everyone ready?
- Swamp cat's now swamp bird!
- And, rolling!
- OK, so this is actually, like, a conspiracy, right?
- Stupid playoff picture. Ciara and I take better photos several million times a day—
- You think you’re the only disgruntled athlete?
- Who the hell are you?
- I’m Clammy and I’m here to talk to you about the Delaware Clams.